and I turn back and I'm not kidding the
deer is up on its back leg like a man
it is chasing us like a man commander
coming
[Music]
you know if we lock down come to Papa
please give up for the Kazan
this is a story about why you shouldn't
smoke pot when you're 10 years old I was
10 years old and I come from a large
Italian family and I'm one of 21
grandchildren and when I was 10 we
started having weddings because the
older kids were older and starting to
get married who started go to these
weddings which when you're 10 is a
pretty kick-ass party up to that point
you're going to birthday parties and
just eating cake and you're pinning a
tail on a donkey and once you realize
everyone cheats anyway the luster comes
off and you're like it's time to move on
but you've got a ways to go before some
really good parties come and then the
wedding started kicking in we're like
this is good we're seeing grown-up like
wasted and people are falling over and
we're seeing girls we never saw before
these are good and we noticed that the
older kids we wanted to hang out with
desperately would all out of the wedding
with Uncle Al at some point in the
wedding they just kind of sneaked away
and we never got asked and we were
bummed out because uncle al his nickname
was uncle al all the kids pal
and when you're 10 you think that's just
because he's fun to be with but the
older kids were like no he's really your
pal
and we're like are what we wanted we
want to go like how do we no one's
asking us to go what are they doing
so this wedding came and we were like
alright we got a up our game so we were
a little ten-year-old business man to me
and my cousin Kenny and we had our
little Shirley Temple and we're leaning
against the bar we had combs in our
pocket we were we were we were working
it and I'm pulling it off totally just
Shirley Temple in your hand when you
tend using the straw and our cousins the
two older comes we really admired we're
looking at it and they started laughing
and I'm like oh maybe it's not going to
happen but then they approach and
they're like hey you uh you want to go
outside and see uncle al right yeah yeah
we do Wow yeah what do we do just go out
front we'll meet you out there and we'll
take you over we'll go see him clout
alright cool
they split we start walking and then my
aunt comes up and she's like where're
you two going
it's just straight in our little ties
like I know where she's like stay away
from your uncle out he'll ruin your life
and we're like now we really want to go
so we walked outside and they take us
through a car and uncle al is sitting in
the car and they get in the car and they
don't let us in the car they roll down
the windows we lean in their little ties
hanging down and they put the window up
to like catch us like we're just stuck
in the car and uncle al has weed out on
his lap on a magazine I mean I'm a man
now I am NOT 10 I am a man I have seen
weave I went to college I used to see
dead shows I've seen weed I'm a man but
to this day I never saw one person have
a bud that was so big as what Uncle Al
had on his lap at his niece's wedding
and we didn't even know was weed he just
started breaking it up we thought they
were just going to like smoke a
cigarette we didn't know that was badass
enough if you were to just smoke
anything so they rolls it up and they
start smoking it and we're stuck in the
window they just start blowing it in our
faces like we're a pet
I can forget a pet hi and just blow it
in their face and we can't we were the
pets in our little suits it may just
blow it is on us and we're getting you
know we're not we don't know we're
getting high we're just trying to be
cool like okay guess this is what you do
with a uncle out there done they roll
down the window and we kind of fall out
and they come out and I remember it was
windy and uncle I was bald except for
the side hair and the wind is blowing in
his hairs all out like this and he just
was going look at me I'm Bozo the Clown
I'm bozo he just heard dancing around
and were like this is why everyone loves
Uncle Al he's a clown
he's amazing so like are you guys can't
walk in with us you guys got to go
around the back be cool all right we'll
be cool and they walk in and we walk
around the back and as soon as we walk
around the back we're lost because we're
high and we're ten we don't know you
even remember there's a wedding we have
to get back to
we're just wandering in our little
business man attire and we come around
the back of these like a golf course
there and there's these little woods you
know like little woods in New Jersey and
I'm probably three trees but wood and
there's a deer there's a deer just
sitting there eating the grass and if
you've ever been high in nature you feel
for some reason like you're one with
nature like there is it speaks to you
whatever it is a rock or an animal and
this deer just kind of looked at us and
we looked at the deer and then we looked
at each other and made the decision of
what to 10 year old kids in Jersey would
decide which is we've got to catch it
now if you're a man and you're in your
business attire you don't just run into
the wood even if it was something great
if it was a bag of money you were like
let's let's change and then we'll go
back and run into the woods but when
you're 10 you just start running in your
businessman suit and the deer took off
and went into the woods we're in the
woods and we're laughing now we're start
you know this is the first time ever 10
first of all everything's funny when
you're 10 then get uncle Al's crazy weed
on top and now you're chasing a deer in
the jungle we're just laughing our asses
up we go running in there the deers like
running and I turn to my cousin I like
Kenny
at what point like if we catch it what
do we do with it he just looks at me
like crazy like it was crazy I think oh
we're gonna eat it
that's a disturbing thing to hear your
cousin say we don't have tools we don't
have cooking we have nothing
no weapon his ideas we're just going to
start biting it like another animal but
I couldn't even focus on that because
I'm looking I look over at the deer the
deer it's like a New Jersey deer that
just heard what we were saying and he
stopped now and looking at it like what
did you say you going to eat me and he
takes a step towards us like a laugh and
we take a step back then he takes two
steps towards us and we take two more
steps back and all of a sudden there's
like that moment where you know you're
under attack and we just start where
we're laughing okay remember when you
were a kid you would be so filled with
joy
sometimes with laughter that your legs
physically don't work that doesn't
happen as an adult you never laughed so
hard that you can't even so pick your
two little lawyers
yeah he's picking up Steve we gotta get
out of here and I'm starting to get a
little further than Kenny and then I
hear Kenny let out a scream like a hi
like there's a reason they put 10 year
old boys in the choir because they can
hit a and a pitch that only angels can
head it's a it's higher than girls it's
so much higher than I can even do it in
the woods I hear that scream a sphere
and it's just I'd like death and angelic
and I'm laughing and I turn back and I'm
not kidding the deer is up on its back
legs like a man it is chasing us like a
man I come in with my scream our suits
are little businessman suits and this
thing is just coming at us
you not eating me we just got to get out
of the woods you just got to get the
hell out of the woods we kind of make
our way it's like he could have like a
taxes but in his head like if I could
read a deer's mind which when I was that
high I kind of did he was like I'm just
gonna scare these little guys these are
the smallest businessmen I've ever seen
I don't even know why they're in the
woods but I'm just going to do the back
leg thing and get them out of here we
make our way out of the woods were
crawling we're mud-covered we're crying
we're not laughing anymore we're crying
we're lost
we see up oh there's the windows of the
party of the wedding and we come up and
we're just like so add we're like we are
wrecked I don't know what I don't I
don't know I'm high but I know this is a
weird day this is the day I'm going to
remember I don't know what they blew in
our faces but I don't want to be at a
wedding I don't want to be a businessman
I don't want to hunt deer with my face
we see Uncle Al he's in there in the
middle of all the parents and he's
telling some animated story and they
were all looking really pissed off I'm
he's laughing with his bozo hair we're
like we can't we got to sit down and get
to catch our breath we sit on these
lounge chairs just like we are wrecked
and all of a sudden my aunt the same
aunt comes
I remember the sky was blue and then all
we just finally chilling out is just
peaceful for a minute and then her face
just came in the middle of that steam
and what did I tell you your uncle's in
there ruining your life
we never got high again until we were 11
thank you guys so much
[Music]